I'd like to welcome you to today's
webinar my name is Dina vanevski and I
will be your moderator today we will be
talking about leading innovation by
design bill is the Thomas Siebel
professor of business leadership
strategy and organizations he's
affiliated faculty at the woods
Institute for the environment here at
Stanford any co-directs the executive
program in strategy and organization
that runs during the summer bill studies
competition among organizations and how
organizations and industries evolve
globally his prior research includes
studies of how strategic differences and
strategic change among organizations
affect their growth performance and
survival it's now my pleasure to turn
things over to Professor Burnett bill
thank you very much for being here with
us today well thank you Dina and thanks
everyone for tuning in we'll be talking
about innovation and innovation by
design over the next hour
many of the ideas we talked about there
is a great deal of research on and
rather than having me go into that
research I'll often refer to my teaching
notes which I put out on a blog for your
reference should you want to take a look
at it and here's the address of that so
that way we don't have to go over things
that I've written about at length so
that's where I put all my teaching notes
and you can take a look there whenever
you want and I guess while I'm plugging
my teaching notes we could also talk
about where you can follow me on Twitter
which once again is Barnette talks
so let's talk about innovation by design
one of the things that we should make
clear first when we talk about
innovation by design is that as a
population we are not good at predicting
the direction of dramatic change and
that's not just true for people
generally who maybe aren't experts
that's especially true for experts when
you look at the big changes that have
come along in systems of innovation over
the years all over the world we have
done a very bad job of predicting them
so take for example the world wide web
in the internet today especially if you
talk to people who are so young that
they've never known the world without
the internet we can't imagine life
without the internet I know my kids
often in the middle of a conversation
will fact check on their smartphone in
the middle of a conversation it's taken
for granted that we can have access to
the world's information but if you go
back to 1990 to 1993 the very early days
the internet existed the world wide web
was just being created in terms of a
massive system where lots of different
computers could go in and then take
content the way that we now take for
granted we had no understanding of where
that was going it's actually very
interesting that at the time our experts
said there was no need for the world
wide web including those who had
invented the technologies for the world
wide web I remember bruno de leon who
was a french software developer and
entrepreneur had created a company that
based on a software that did
manipulation of photographs and back in
1992 1993 bruno was a visitor in my
class on organizational growth and bruno
took the stage after we talked about
their technology and he talked about the
future and he said he envisioned a
future
where lots of people would go on to
computers not to use the computer but to
access photographs from other people's
computers now you hear that today and
you say but of course well I can tell
you at the end of that class when I
looked at my class ratings they were
fine except for the bruno de leon
session and the students were convinced
that this guy was out of his mind and
that we shouldn't be having him back in
again and yet he was the one person I
remember from that era who was actually
talking about the way we use computers
today and when you go through the
archives as I have done you find there
very little understanding of where
technologies are going so that's the
first thing I think we have to get clear
we aren't good at predicting innovation
and our experts are particularly not
good at predicting innovation but a
second point to make when it comes to
understanding innovation is that we're
really good at retrospectively
rationalizing once an innovation comes
about we quickly realize collectively
what the meaning of an innovation is and
come to assume it and obviously the web
is an example of that we now take for
granted that it exists but another great
example are these Business School case
studies that you often read about
successful companies they're often
written up in a way that seems so
compelling that the opportunity was so
clear often the innovations are talked
about as if they were planned I was
sitting on University Avenue in Palo
Alto enjoying the sunshine a couple of
weeks ago and I overheard a couple of
people probably in their 20s talking
about Facebook
now I've followed Facebook since its
beginning with case studies and most
people know about the road that Facebook
has followed to success as being one
that really emerged through lots of
different unexpected developments and
yet to hear them talk about Facebook the
platform strategy the monetization model
you would think that it had been planned
by a mass
chess-player and it's that kind of
retrospective rationalization that we're
so good at in a way we look at companies
often the way we look at a person's
career you know a company's strategy is
a lot like a person's resume it is a
retrospective rationalization of that
company's life just like a resume is a
retrospective rationalization of your
career
it's accurate factually your resume is
accurate but there's nobody's life that
really reads like a resume I often joke
that nobody's resume says moved to
Boston for a girl yet it happens all the
time one of my sons did it I don't know
if he's tuned in today to the webinar
but ultimately he and the girl married
and so we have evidence that that was
why he moved to Boston his resume says
something about Harvard that's the
retrospective rationalization of what
happened and you can think of your own
resumes that way now I raise this topic
of the resume and rationalization and
retrospective rationalization of
businesses not to be cynical but to be
honest about the fact that what unfolds
makes sense to us only in retrospect and
as humans we are really good at
retrospectively rationalizing not only
that it is our job as a leader to
retrospectively rationalize why our firm
wins or why our firm loses so I'm not
cynical at all about retrospective
rationalization I just want to point out
that that's what goes on in
organizational life now when you put
these two facts together number one that
we are not good at predicting innovation
and number two that we are really good
at retrospectively rationalizing it
creates a problem we tend to be very bad
at organizing for innovation and and to
explain my point here let me tell a
story
I remember going to Singapore in the
late 90s to lecture on this same topic
on organizing for innovation and as many
of you may know Singapore as a system as
a as a city-state as a society is
extremely good at planning and you only
have to go through their Airport to
enjoy the fruits of that I often wish
that many of the other airports of the
world would outsource their operations
to Singapore because Singapore is so
good at planning as I'm there in
Singapore I noticed in the mall that was
Wat by the Weston hotel there was a
street musician playing a guitar and he
was very clean had a poncho on it was
air-conditioned of course being
Singapore he was singing Peter Paul and
Mary songs Puff the Magic Dragon or
something like that now all my education
took place in Berkley so I know about
street musicians on average they don't
sound that good they're not very
pleasant they often are not someone
you'd want to hang out with these
Singapore street musicians were actually
very nice people
they looked approachable in fact there
was a second one that I saw that night
in the lobby of the shangri-la now at
that point I knew that there was a
pattern nothing happens in Singapore by
accident anyway never mind twice well
come to find out that the campaign that
was going on in Singapore that year was
to increase creep to increase creativity
and spontaneity and these street
musicians were part of that campaign now
think about this let's think about the
innovation process what's going on in
the case of the Singapore story
here's a distribution of possible
outcomes and you don't know what you're
going to get in the innovation process
some of your outcomes in fact are very
unpleasant so here's my technical symbol
for that some of them are gonna look
like genius later and who knows what the
real distribution looks like here I have
most of our innovations being sort of
envy
Queen and think of musicians for example
we want to have a musical genius come
out of a system we want to come up with
the next Neil Young or Bob Dylan or
whoever you see as a musical genius but
the system is going to give us lots of
riff raff along the way down here
well Singapore looked at this problem
they said we would like to have
creativity so they managed it they know
how to plan but in that planning what do
they do here's the distribution of
outcomes they produce we're not going to
have any of that foolishness first of
all none of those avoidable street
musicians I used to see in Berkeley oh
the implications of that planning is
that neither will we have genius over
here in a sense the price of genius is
foolishness
when we manage the innovation process
look what we do we manage away variants
the key to innovation is variance yet
most of our managerial systems right
there's our variance most of our
managerial systems manage for the mean
in here and this is the problem with
managing innovation especially given the
way that we retrospectively rationalize
we think of course we can identify
innovation but no we only identify
innovation after we know the difference
between the fools and the geniuses and
that only happens once we allow variants
to take place it's one of the biggest
problems we face in the management of
innovation is the fact that we tend to
manage away the variance of the system
therefore while we get no foolishness
neither do we get genius
so what do we do what are the
implications of this well it turns out
we can manage to increase variance we
can think about increasing the
variability of what is produced by a
system but it requires a very different
philosophical approach to how we lead
organizations and if I had to boil it
down deena I would boil it down to this
following statement our job in leading
innovation is not to know the future our
job is to create the system that
discovers that future and that means
creating organizations and larger
ecosystems of organizations that have
high variance as one of their
characteristics that produce lots of
foolishness and failure as the price we
pay to get those moments of genius we've
had a bunch of questions already about
what you've been saying some about using
models to look at what's happened in the
past and try and predict what might
happen in the future but then you just
mentioned having all these different
ways of innovating I guess doing
different work so how do you how do you
do that how do you take an organization
that typically develops one or two
products and allow for that type of
innovation or innovative work yes now of
course there's a tremendous amount of
work on this dino with respect to the in
of managing the innovation process and I
think if I had to boil it down
especially when we're talking about
predictive models remember every model
predicts a distribution of outcomes it
has an on average prediction but it also
has if you will of variance and so in a
way our best models the ones that are
most accurate are the ones that are in
many ways minimizing variance so
ironically while they'll do a very good
job of predicting those things in the
future that should follow from what
we've already experienced in the past
precisely for that reason
they'll do a very bad job of predicting
completely new realities let me give you
an example
I studied the evolution of the computer
industry in a in a book that I published
a few years ago I'm not plugging the
book in fact my wife describes it as a
book that was written not to be read so
I'll sum up everything you would ever
want to know out of that book in the
next minute and so don't bother with not
reading it but in looking at the history
of the computer industry the early firms
those in the mainframe era were
tremendous at modeling changes as they
were taking place in terms of the
mainframe computer it wasn't just IBM
there were a number of firms involved a
tremendous amount of technological
expertise took us from the very early
computers through to computers that were
used in large-scale industry and
government and military and so forth now
famously and probably most of you know
this story
computing changed coming into the 1960s
moving into the 1970s and and into the
1980s during during that period there
was a shift towards what we now talk
about as distributed computing this is
prior to the personal computer prior to
the microcomputer a shift in the logic
of computing if you do want to read
about it actually the novel soul of a
new machine is a great reference for
that and many of the companies that were
starting up then began to use a new term
the term was hacking and hacker there
was a hacker code of ethics that said
computing should be accessible to all
that there should be a much more
distributed bottom-up approach now
albeit the fact that most of the people
involved in that movement had the
largesse of Stanford in MIT at their
disposal so it wasn't quite a populist
movement but nonetheless the idea was
that you could access computers from a
distributed system rather than through a
centralized mainframe system what turns
out that that logic everything about
that logic
of organizing competing designing
computers was so different than anything
that you could imagine in the mainframe
era that all those models of the
development of the mainframe computer
that emphasized scale and economies of
scale were in a sense disrupted by this
movement to distributed computing the
better you did at developing the
mainframe the more inappropriate was
everything about what you did for
distributed computing and therefore the
mainframe firms that tried to move into
distributed computing failed now here's
what's really ironic about this once the
distributed computing firms came to
blossom the Digital Equipment
corporations data general many of these
much stories innovative firms they were
talked about then as the obviously novel
disruptive organizations well men along
comes the micro computer with the
microprocessor the micro computer is yet
again another logic of computing that
was completely different from the design
characteristics of distributed computing
systems required a different kind of
organization much more focused on
distribution much more of an inclusion
of the general public and retail markets
and so forth completely different
approach to software design as late as
the early 1980s in the Stanford library
there's still our compute books on the
computer industry that dismissed the
micro computer as a toy used a for
trivial computing purposes once again a
disruption had arrived it had come along
where our old logic didn't apply to the
new logic the old models weren't good at
predicting the new development and the
new developments were taking the world
in a completely different direction now
look I bring up this example not because
it's exceptional these kinds of changes
these completely unexpected
transformations of industry through
innovation
then across all industries and are
happening at an increasing rate my point
is that the models that predict because
they're based on history are
particularly bad at under at at at
predicting how these innovations will
take place the economy in different
economies are better or worse at this
but the economy allows for lots of
variants and so the high variance parts
of the economy are the parts of the
economy that come up with these
innovations you know many people come to
Silicon Valley in order to understand
innovation and they will come from other
countries I'll say we would love to have
a Silicon Valley and the very first
thing I say is well let's look at your
failure rate and you often get surprised
they say no we actually would prefer not
to have failure we want to have the
innovation as it would of course but the
best predictor of innovation that is
genius is whether or not this system is
allowing for failure because that tells
me it's a high variance system and it's
a high variance system that produces
both genius and folly and typically up
ends the models that were predictive in
the past this is amazing we've had a lot
of questions about that and first
someone was asking about you can't you
just respond quickly to other changes
that are going on but then when you look
at the technologies it doesn't seem like
you could really keep up so it seems
like you need to have a large group of
people working on lots of different
projects and so can you talk a little
bit about how you how do you do that how
do you make it safe for people to fail
in a company knowing that you have no
idea what's going to happen in the
future and that one of those things
might be the new direction of your
company that's a good a good question
Dena and it's it's typically the one
that comes up at this point once again
there is a lot of work on this I guess
to sum it up I would say that what
matters most is knowing whether or not
you're trying to capitalize on existing
technologies or whether or not you're
trying to move in directions that are
likely to be disruptive because look
when we're
to capitalise on existing technologies
we we need to focus on what is already
known and plan for time to market given
those technologies let's talk about
Seagate as a great example of this when
Steve Lu so initially took over as CEO
of Seagate and now I'm going way back to
the late 90s right around the turn of
the century that company was a
technological leader that had been
perennial unprofitable and when you look
at why it had to do with the fact that
it was constantly lagging in time to
market will Steve shifted Seagate at
that time to a time to market strategy
and the way he did that was to remind
the organization and really move the
culture and structure and routines of
the organization to emphasize using only
existing technologies so that they could
make customer defined time milestones
right so if you're gonna come out of
course we're going back in time now but
you know you're coming out with say 20
megabyte discs drive that say a consumer
products company like Adele or maybe a
disc array firm like an EMC needs by a
certain date then you got to make that
date and if you're gonna miss that day
to not have those technological
specifications because you were trying
to push the edge of technology that's
unacceptable so interestingly Seagate
became much more responsive on time to
market but it did so by focusing on
existing technologies meanwhile
simultaneously in a separate part of the
organization Steve Lou so and his team
put together a Seagate research which
was based back it's a long story I won't
tell you all the details and I write
about it in my teaching notes on my blog
but it was based elsewhere it was
separate from much of the organization's
production processes and that part of
the organization did a lot more blue sky
research and the fundamentals of
material science so that they were ready
to begin to incorporate solid-state
memory
and other kinds of memory which we now
see combined with what you'd think of as
traditional disk drives and the much
more hybrid products that you see today
so there were both of these efforts
going on here at Stanford our professor
charles o'reilly has done a great deal
of research on this mixing of the focus
on exploiting what we know and the
organizing to explore what we don't know
but i have to say that even though there
has been a great deal of work especially
by professor o'reilly and his colleagues
on this difficult problem it is a
problem because after all let's go back
to that distribution okay so if this is
this distribution who knows what it's
actually shaped like perhaps it's skewed
differently and down here we have these
ideas that aren't going to work out and
up here we have these ideas that are
going to work out in the economy when
these innovations come along the economy
draws a selection threshold okay and
these firms these efforts these
innovations are going to be deselected
and the evolutionary process of the
economy leaves us with these successful
firms you have to ask yourself where do
the costs of failure go in the economy
and the answer in capitalism is that
those costs are what the finance markets
in a sense distribute across risk takers
according to the level of risks that is
seen in these projects so the capitalism
is actually reasonably good at allowing
for this kind of an experimentation
process when you try to explore for new
possibilities inside companies in a
sense you bring inside the company these
costs which means wide open blue sky
innovation could be cost prohibitive I'm
going to put it another way if you're
gonna if you really want to win the
lottery you'll buy all the lottery
tickets but that's not a as Business
School professors would put it positive
net present value proposition
though we have a bunch of questions on
that as well and so even if you have
your research area or even a group of
people who can fail trying to create
that sense that you can fail how do you
reward the failure hmm yeah well you
know that's a it's a tough thing and I
think one of the ways to look at the
problem is to break the different
techniques of organizing and leadership
into the different parts some are easier
to deal with than others so let's look
at the easiest to deal with and that
would be the sort of architecture and
routines of your organization reporting
relationships structures incentives
those you can typically manipulate
reasonably easily compared to say
changing the kind of people that work in
an organization or changing the culture
of an organization those are harder to
deal with so if we look at the easier to
deal with techniques the organization
structure its routines they're what we
see is that the most innovative
organizations are on the one hand
structured in a way that they separate
out those who must make the numbers on a
quarter to quarter basis from those who
are exploring for new possibilities and
it's once again Charles Orion Professor
Charles O'Reilly work that has looked a
lot at this separation of the different
parts of what he terms the ambidextrous
organization but also then if you look
at the different routines and so for
example incentive systems which were
implied by your question Deena they're
there the jury's out incentive systems
can become too complicated if I had to
boil down what I've seen in the research
so far I would say it's not exactly
determinant but there is some evidence
that incentive systems that work on
behavior rather than outcome are more
forgiving with respect to failure
alright so think this through if someone
is your direct report and they've done
what in your book are the right things
with respect to a process of innovation
but it hasn't worked out
you can reward them for having gone
through the process of innovating even
though in that particular trial it
hasn't worked out we can take a great
lesson here from the world of
entrepreneurs the big movement now in
entrepreneurship following the work of
Eric Ries and Steve Blank really takes
us back to the old theories of the great
professor James March many of the ideas
that I'm talking about on innovation
came out of James marches work and if
you had to boil it down this approach
says as follows it's written at at
length by Ries and blank as well as
James March and his students if you had
to boil it down the innovation process
comes down to this we try something we
find out why it doesn't work and then we
update and you know for those of you who
studied the scientific method in school
you know you have your theory which
we're going to call a strategy and then
you take that and you test it
empirically as a scientist would in the
sciences we're gonna call that the
market or the customer and then based on
what goes wrong here with the customer
we update the strategy now if we spend a
lot of time up here in a planning
process planning the strategy we better
hope to be right because we put a lot of
money into it and sunk a lot of time if
instead we minimize how much time we
spend planning and as quickly as
possible go to the customer we learn why
we're wrong more quickly and go through
this iterative process of learning which
as many of our viewers know has become
very popular in Silicon Valley and the
Lean Startup movement and in fact many
large organizations are using when they
engage in agile development processes
and other such processes that rely on
iterative improvement now remember the
secret iterative improvement is not
getting it right initially it's getting
a process of learning in place so that
we converge over time on a better
solution through
and error now there are a lot of
problems with this and so I'm not saying
this is a panacea I remember being asked
to speak on this topic to a group of
airline executives in a restaurant that
was overlooking San Francisco Airport
which would have been fine except that
down on the runway was the burned-out
hull of the airliner that tragically had
had crash landing at San Francisco
Airport here about a year ago it was
very difficult for me with a straight
face to talk about the importance of
failure and the need to fail to a bunch
of people in the Aeronautics industry
overlooking the burned-out hull of an
aircraft I don't want a lot of
foolishness if someone is running a
nuclear power plant there are lots of
times we don't want to see failure in
fact if I want a nuclear power plant run
I probably want to put Singapore on the
job because we're not going to see any
foolishness so you have to do this kind
of approach to innovation in an
appropriate way and it may be that a lot
of prototyping and developing goes on
behind the scenes before a product is
declared ready for launching as as a
final product you look at the American
changes in the American healthcare
system it wasn't surprising to a lot of
us here in the Silicon Valley that the
initial rollout of the software to sign
up people for healthcare had a lot of
problems that's often how software is
developed it was probably it was clearly
inappropriate to run the experiment in
real time on the American people while
they were supposed to be signing up for
healthcare you really should have gone
through that iterative process of
development in prototypes on test
markets in advance so that the rollout
ends up being a much better product and
yet when you look at those who are now
retrospectively rationalizing the flawed
rollout of the healthcare software
there's a lot of talk about couldn't
have been planned better no this wasn't
an issue of planning it's that the
development process for something really
different requires lots of iterative
learning and that wasn't built into that
development process in advance so we've
had a few questions on how to finance
innovation so how much money is there
any research that tells a company how
much they should be spending on people
who aren't really creating anything
that's going to come to market quickly
yeah yeah well it turns out that it is
very difficult for firms to imitate
venture capitalists and so I don't know
if the question really wanted to go with
that let me go at that issue though so
the venture capital community is a very
different approach to finance than what
we see in many other communities one of
the prominent venture capital firms here
in Silicon Valley for example had a bit
of a crisis a couple of years ago some
of my colleagues were among their
leadership and I was very interested to
hear how they dealt with the crisis they
had found they had a real problem with
the failure rate of their portfolio
companies the problem was that their
failure rate was going down they were
becoming concerned that their access to
deal flow their view of what was going
on in terms of new venture creation was
perhaps becoming too conservative they
were getting not enough foolishness
now that itself would be a problem
except that it might imply they're not
getting enough genius and so once again
going back to that model where you want
to increase variants the perspective the
venture community is of the most
successful firms is to magnify that
variance and in not it not because
you're trying to make money out of 90%
of your ventures no you're only going to
be making money out of a very small
proportion of your ventures
now that model works well for firms that
specialize in it and come to understand
the logic of investing for variants sake
it does not work so well the empirical
record shows for corporations for
businesses it's often very difficult for
the internal corporate venturing arm of
business to in a sense imitate what goes
on in the venture capital community and
that empirical fact itself should cause
people inside large corporations to
think twice before they try to play the
game of the venture capitalists I think
it's much more important for businesses
to have strategic direction to
understand why they go to work every day
and to try to make good on the
investments that are already in place
and let me return again to the example I
gave you earlier of Steve Liu so at
Seagate for years ever since solid-state
flash memory came along people have been
worrying about what would go on with the
Winchester and the disk drive and so
forth and and yet during that period of
great concern Steve and his team managed
to continue to make money and there been
ups and downs in that business as there
are in any business but they could not
take their eye off the ball that they
were supplying large numbers of storage
devices to companies all over the world
and that is a very different strategic
tasks than experimenting in going in new
directions do they need to have that
kind of experimentation absolutely but
that doesn't make them venture
capitalists the venture capital business
is a very different business and I would
caution firms that try to simply imitate
the venture capital model so going back
to the rewarding failure how how long do
you let someone go on a path of
something and and had but well I'll just
stop with that how long how long do you
let it go and then how do you
communicate that to the rest of the
company to so that the people on the
company
who are working on something that's
failing all the time aren't seen as
lesser than the people who are creating
the products yeah yeah you know Dena
this is this is the big question this is
the million dollar question right so
let's let's take a look at the way that
great change comes about if this is the
performance of an organization and we
know these on performance changes over
time right so we're going to have
performance changing over time when
we're here in terms of our performance
if if we let's say if we stay the course
we would just keep performance as is
just hypothetically but if we move in a
new strategic direction there's going to
be risk of course we have a vision of
getting to a much higher level of
performance by making a strategic change
the trouble is we have to get from here
to here right we have to somehow get get
up there and and the the execution of
this is not a median which a Dina in
your question is the underlying issue
here's what actually happens when an
innovation is successful winning in win
a big innovation is successful it
actually makes performance worse
initially until at some point and this
varies by context and the nature of the
innovation we end up improving
performance and of course the exact
shape of this curve can vary some people
talk about it as the so-called J curve
now this is a problem because if we're
down here you're working in an
organization down there and things have
been getting worse you're looking at
leadership saying I'm not sure what you
folks are doing but things are worse
today than they were yesterday
and then if leadership stays the course
they say yeah but now look things are
even worse today than they were
yesterday and when we talk about
leadership often leadership in a process
of innovation has to make clear the
logic of what must be true up here which
helps your people understand why it is
that we're having to endure the
difficult process of change in order to
get there
that's why strategy is important getting
back to that iterative learning process
I was describing earlier things might
not get better as we iterate we might be
learning about changes we have to make
that are especially difficult
lots of end to end solutions that
require the whole system to shift are
very difficult I remember when years ago
the folks at Qualcomm we're talking
about a future Irwin Jacobs Paul Jacobs
and their turn team we're talking about
a future where the wireless system would
move large amounts of data now today of
course we take that for granted in the
retrospective rationalization process
that I was talking about earlier but at
the time that ruined Jacobs and Paul
Jacobs and that team at Qualcomm were
first talking about that future there
was a tremendous amount of debate about
whether that was true in fact in
testifying before the European
regulators on the subject of whether the
standard that Qualcomm was developing
so-called CDMA technology back then and
of course there's been a lot of
technical change since then but but in
that debate which is now a couple of
decades ago the European regulators in
fact chose to not allow CDMA technology
into the European system because they
were unconvinced that it was going to be
effective there had been professors here
at Stanford who had engineering
professors who had published that the
ideas behind Irwin Jacobs innovation
violated the laws of physics so a
tremendous amount of disagreement and
yet the folks in the Qualcomm team
remained convinced that although it was
difficult at first that ultimately if
they could get a system in place that
allowed for the efficient digitization
of data that we would be able to do a
tremendous
amount of movement of that data among
small handheld devices which of course
turned out to be true but it was much
debated for years when those systems
were were really those of you who lived
through that as consumers remember it
was hard to get a phone call never mind
pull up a website or make reservations
all the kinds of things we do today now
we're closer to having fulfilled that
vision but getting from here to there is
a very difficult road it requires a
belief by people and organizations in
their strategy it requires leadership
that aims at that end state and what's
interesting is it doesn't mean that the
leaders know all the details about what
will have to unfold to get there but
they know what the end state is and they
help their people understand the logic
of that business wow I'm just thinking
about that a little bit because they're
how to communicate that to everyone and
how to be a strong leader is sounds very
challenging can you talk a little bit
about how you might help the
organization move towards I guess having
that sort of strategy and having that
sort of leadership that can really stay
the course yeah that's a good question I
mean we've seen it happen in the form of
strong leaders as you say Dina and
obviously Steve Jobs comes to mind when
I give leadership lectures around the
world I often ask the audience's that I
face the question who what is an example
of a great leader and one of the things
I find so amusing is that I'll often
have a military leaders religious
leaders brought up depending on context
I've had audiences name as they're great
as examples of great leaders Genghis
Khan Jesus Christ
the Prophet Mohammed Mahatma Gandhi
Napoleon Vladimir Putin was brought up
recently guess where I was
and but in almost every situation people
named Steve Jobs and clearly he's seen
as the icon for this kind of visionary
leadership people used to say that Steve
was surrounded by a so called reality
distortion field now the point there is
if Steve believes something was possible
it often helped others to come to
believe that that was possible here's
the problem prior to Steve's fantastic
successes in recent years before his
tragic and early death prior to that if
you go back into the 1990s Steve Jobs
was often looked at as an example of bad
leadership style and it's hard for us to
even imagine that now but there were
case studies about Steve using a very
dogmatic approach to leadership and
firing people when maybe that wasn't
appropriate Steve's on board unseated
him as people may know if they've read
about the the Steve Jobs story the the
jury was out so if we go back to our J
curve and if we go back to our J curve
there were times for Steve when he was
down here and at that point a lot of
people had doubts about him it's also
true that it wasn't clear that Steve
knew what Apple was going to look like
once it came up here what he did do is
he put in place a system that could
discover it and so you know I think you
want to think about that in terms of
what we do as leaders you know as
leaders it may be that we don't actually
know the direction the organization
needs to go in but instead we want to
create a system that can discover it one
of the ways I like to to help people
think about this is to run through the
following thought experiment ask
yourself this question when you have a
good idea does everybody have to agree
with that idea for it to be correct and
most people if I ask them that question
will say well no I'm my own person I
could come up with an idea and even if
people don't agree with it it might be
correct and yet
when we have an idea ask yourself what's
the first thing we do we ask people we
turn to other people he said what do you
think of this and if the people we ask
don't like the idea what do we do then
we often ask someone else so what is it
we're doing on the one hand we say we
don't need to have everybody agree with
us in order for an idea to be good on
the other hand we tend to really care
about what other people think well
here's what I think's going on there
so just bear with me as I run through
this okay look when we have an idea
that's innovative we might be right but
of course we might be wrong and the more
interesting the idea the less we can
know in advance which is which or to put
it another way if we know in advance we
have enough information to know the
difference between genius and
foolishness the idea isn't that
innovative but what we can detect right
away is whether or not people agree with
us if we ask other people and they're
all agreeing with us we've got ourselves
a consensus idea if we ask other people
and there's a lot of debate and a lot of
the people that we ask do not agree
let's call that an on consensus idea
okay so look at the situation we're in
what can we observe we can observe
whether people agree or whether they
don't agree what do we wish we could
observe we wish we could observe whether
we're right or whether we're wrong and
we can't tell now for sake of discussion
let's imagine we're right where would
you rather be if you knew you were right
well if you think that through look back
at that Irwin Jacobs story you want to
be non-consensus because if you're right
and people are saying you're violating
the laws of physics
in the end you're gonna own all the
intellectual property you're going to
have a tremendous advantage and in fact
when you hear of the tremendous amount
of intellectual property payments that
go to Qualcomm those were earned by that
firm being in the right non-consensus
box early on if everyone already agreed
with us we'd all be right that's fine
it's just not as profitable as being
right in a non consensus sense but Deana
now look at this what if we're wrong if
we're wrong
where do you want to be then and there
is no doubt if you're wrong
you just don't want to be alone because
nobody wants to be here this is the fool
and the big problem we face in trying to
manage innovation is that the fear of
being a fool is often much stronger than
the hope of being a genius because of
that odds are people in your
organization have ideas that they are
afraid to come forward with people will
side to consensus thinking even though
they might have brilliant ideas and the
question you have to ask yourself as a
leader is that have you created an
environment in your organization where
it's safe for people to risk being a
fool and if the answer to that is no you
are not going to hear the ideas that
potentially are genius
Wow again can't help thinking about how
you how you know on the Jaykar the how
you know if you are actually on the J
curve versus just heading towards a
failure and how how you help people who
don't like change
yeah so again you're heading in this
path you're trying to help people fail
and you're trying to find the genius and
you're surrounded by people who want
results and who don't sort of I guess
honor or respect the failure so how do
you help that The Fool yeah yeah you
know it's it's constantly around the
business school Idina we hear people
saying you know I've come here to learn
about best business practice or we've
come here to understand how to interpret
the evidence we're getting and our
quarterly results we're very inductive
from data that way we want to see the
results how do i how can i tell how can
i model this how can i know if the idea
is really innovative you can't know with
respect to the experience of the firm
there is risk that's unavoidable what we
can do in advance is elaborate on our
logic the Stanford Business School and
our new curriculum has focused greatly
on helping our students think logically
about strategy and the reason we do this
is that the the what leadership can do
is offer an a logic for where it is the
firm wants to go now that logic can have
flaws and will need to be updated in an
iterative way as evidence comes in but
the nature of innovation is that if the
innovation is big enough we don't have
the data now to know we didn't have the
data in 1990 to know how we would look
at the world wide web by 2000 we didn't
have the data when they were first
making social network sites to realize
that they would be platforms for sharing
pictures within 10 years of their
founding and we can go through example
after example such as we've done over
this the course of this webinar but what
we did have was the capacity to engage
in logic and it is a primary job for
leadership
to help their people understand the
logic of the business the strategy is a
retrospective rationalization of what
we've done as a firm but it is also a
roadmap for the logic that should get us
through the j-curve are we going to be
right of course not in fact we need to
build failure into the system as we
discover our way through the j-curve but
without leadership and logic if all
we're relying on our short-term results
we are never going to take the kind of
risk that gets us to that much higher
level of innovation that's great you
know I want to just mention that if we
were in one of your programs which I
highly recommend people would have time
to ask you questions throughout the
presentation but also to talk with you
on breaks and at mealtimes and so we
have a lot of questions that we're not
going to be able to get to but I just
want to make sure that everybody is
aware that the in our programs it you
get to continue the conversation both
with the faculty member and with the the
cohort and so we don't have a huge
amount of time left and there are a lot
of things that you've said that I want
to make sure that we repeat and get out
and so if you could just come back to
sort of the communicating failures I
mean I think you've touched on the
strategy which is really wonderful well
maybe we could just end with how you
communicate the failures so that
everyone doesn't doesn't make the same
mistake again or that maybe someone else
can find that path and move on yeah you
know it's a it's a difficult thing and I
brought up the example of Qualcomm
before and I'd like to raise it again as
an example the chief learning officer at
Qualcomm is a woman named tomorrow el
colas and has provided I think a lot of
us with a tremendous example of how to
deal with the question that you asked
Dina it's been a very successful company
she's been their chief Learning Officer
for years what's interesting is as a
c-level officer right there with top
management
she's been really pushing on the
innovation process and in particular
when you come to be a Qualcomm employee
like every firm you go through
initial process of orientation what's
interesting at Qualcomm is you will you
will hear films and many of those films
are top level Qualcomm leaders talking
about their greatest failures and you
know from the from the beginning they
focus on the fact that well-intended
behavior that leads to failing outcomes
have very good implications obviously
you don't want behaviors that are
against policy or in some way
nefarious that's not what we're getting
at but we're talking about people trying
to do their job where there's an
inherent element of risk and things
don't go well if that's a career-ending
event people throughout an organization
know that and then they get very
conservative and the great innovative
organizations of the world try to create
a culture where in some contexts it's
safe to be innovative